isolated by the west but not here
Russia's foreign minister Sergey lavrov
receives a warm welcome in mali's
capital bamako greeted by Abdullah the
country's foreign minister the two
countries are seeking greater
cooperation with Mali wanting help
combating armed groups linked to isil
and Al-Qaeda
last year and the start of this year
cooperation in Military and Military
technical areas was given a new page in
their development a large Consignment of
Russian Aviation Technology was sent
thanks to which mali's army was able to
conduct successful operations against
the terrorists Who Remain active on
their territory the Marine Army hired
hundreds of Russian fighters from the
Wagner group in December 2021 to regain
control of lost territory it's been
unhappy with the decade-long presence of
the largest and most expensive U.N
peacekeeping operation five thousand
French soldiers left last year as
relations with Paris deteriorated but
the violence has continued Millions have
been forced from their homes
our brothers that we left behind are
suffering enormously they want to flee
but the humanitarian situation is
deteriorated people are so scared
because there is no one out there to
protect them armed Fighters are ruling
areas where the state is absent
independent human rights experts have
accused Russian mercenaries and Malian
forces of possible war crimes and crimes
against humanity following a briefing at
the U.N security Council last week Mali
throughout the U.N peacekeeping Mission
human rights Chief accusing him of bias
over the last year the country has
expelled several International diplomats
accusing them of meddling in the
country's Affairs now it's seeking
better ties with Moscow seen as a foe to
the west but not to many countries in
West Africa
lavross visit to the region comes at a
time when Russia appears increasingly
isolated in the west but for countries
in the Sahel here Russia appears to be a
better alternative to France the former
colonial power whose forces have so far
failed to bring stability and peace to
the region but at what cost Russia wants
access to mali's minerals and Mali needs
greater military cooperation access to
wheat and fertilizer Mali is
increasingly isolated it sees Russia as
a partner as it faces a mounting
security and humanitarian crisis
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera